[Music]
come on you can do this
we are outgoing the only way to catch
this crew is in the ACT you're going New
York turn up the issue I'm dying to give
you the problem
with the opinion of the department that
Shane's night wasn't hunting bank
robbers he be robbing thanks that might
be raffle on the edges but he's a good
cop This Crew is tight they move like a
team you got a theory or Road lead back
to a businessman cause by winner
I hope I'm not uh interrupting what can
I do you for yeah a lot of X Pros I had
a couple of them for a message out
anything about that not to the best of
my recollection think real hard
FBI CIA agf all have open cases on
Winner and two city cops from La walk in
here and they think they're gonna handle
this hey
served in the Marines seems to have some
disciplinary hearing every year I was
thinking but it would try your way in
tonight is the most dangerous piece on
the board hello [ __ ] and strike when
you least expect it
oh friend are you uh trying to be funny
no I can pick you up whenever I want
wherever I want
how can you be at the wrong place at the
right time all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
trick or treat mother
[Music]